yo what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to a small
little update video uh what am i going
to call this one
update 3.1 sorry 5 stars anyway guys
this this video is going to be uh first
of all a thank you video because i just
hit the big 2 000 subscriber mark so
thank you very much i really do
appreciate everyone and i do thank
everyone personally uh who has
subscribed to my videos so if you have
gotten a thank you message or comment
from me just let me know because i
appreciate that you guys get my messages
and you know i get the word out so thank
you for helping me reach 2 000
subscribers also something interesting
happened today and i probably should not
have made it through the day because i
witnessed a f1
funnel cloud
i was tweeting about it before i posted
some pictures on twitter uh i twit
picked them so i'll be doing a tutorial
on how to send pictures from your phone
which
might not be an iphone or an iphone 3g
or anything like that and have a twitter
client and you can send them straight to
twitter and um
if you want to go ahead and follow me on
twitter and you'll see more cool
pictures like that i got some pretty
awesome pictures of the storm and the
thunderstorm they're pretty sweet in
fact i'll try to throw up a video of the
uh storm that i took with my phone
unfortunately i didn't get the twister
itself on camera but uh as you can see
it was pretty intense the way it was
hailing we got lightning and we just got
another subscriber no but seriously guys
enjoy your summer uh i know i will be
too and i have about one more month left
of summer i i've officially decided i'm
gonna try to upload a video once every
two days and sometimes once every three
days but basically uh it's not really a
finite schedule but um it's not gonna be
like three a day or anything like that
so just letting you guys know and one
more part to this update video i might
be giving away um
a griffin elevator so follow me on
twitter for more exclusive updates about
you know when or how i might be giving
that away i'm gonna stop plugging my own
twitter no one wants to follow me anyway
but yeah seriously leave a comment below
if you would like to see a griffin
elevator giveaway or some other giveaway
of some product i've reviewed just go
ahead and look in my past videos leave a
comment saying
what
that i've already reviewed that you
would like me to give away because
there's a lot of things up in here i'm
not giving away my microphone but
seriously pick something and you know
check it out oh one last thing another
fellow youtube user uh by the name of
pablo silvan i believe that's how you
say it he's a member of the mkbhd group
submitted an intro video that i think
you guys should check out do you think i
should switch out my intro keep the
music change the music i'll give you
guys a little preview of it right there
and while watching that leave a comment
maybe you think that should be a good
intro possible intro and um you know
it's pretty good so
thanks for watching this update video
um
i'm just gonna let you watch that now
seriously thanks for watching this uh
update video and uh thanks for
subscribing if you have already and uh
go ahead and rate that bad boy 5 stars
and i'll catch you guys in the next
review wraps for you coming up guys talk
to you later peace
you